i don't want to come on as uh
leading the anti-science charge i think
science has its place
the problem that i meet and i also spend
a fair bit of time with scientists and
the good ones there's no problem with
because the good ones operate
fully in the light of the philosophy of
science
and the history of science they know
what they're doing
but the work a day bench scientist
tends to be extremely doctrinaire and
extremely intolerant
of what he regards as
thinking not as rigorous as his own
however most scientists are not
philosophers of science and they
suffer they're from because science
is a historical phenomenon it arose
with the greeks and developed through
the arabs in the middle ages and into
its modern
phase like all historically evolved
human
institutions its earliest assumptions
were made in the greatest atmosphere of
naivete
you see the earliest assumptions are
always the most naive assumptions
because they occur in the adolescent
in the adolescence or childhood of a
discipline
so science makes a number of assumptions
which it
is not willing to examine
one is that the time when
an experiment is performed is
not a factor which should
affect the results in other words if we
say
sulfur melts at a certain temperature
we don't have to add that it does that
on tuesdays
and thursdays and that on on other days
it melts at a different temperature
by making that assumption that
time is an invariant quality
science has precluded its
ability to ever explain anything
except phenomena which are of so low
grade a organizational level that they
are in fact
invariant in time this is why science
has had such
success explaining the behavior of a
first of all inorganic matter and
in large and small aggregates and much
less
success in biology and to my mind almost
no success in psychology and theories of
history and that
sort of thing so that's just one of the
assumptions that scientists make that
temporal invariance and of course what
i've tried to say tonight
is that everything is in flux the whole
philosophy that stands behind the iching
and pythagoreanism and all of that is a
philosophy of eternal change
and another uh well
when you actually study the
philosophy of science what you learn
is two things first of all there's
something called
girdles fear incompleteness
theorem which people are not aware of
but
certainly should be because it bears
centrally on the formation of ideas in
the 20th century
girdle was a mathematician who showed
that in
any formal system including a
mathematical system
it is possible to generate true
statements which are not uh
allowable by the formal laws within the
system
in other words no formal system can
generate all true statements about
itself
well what this means is that
the kind of truth which science has held
as its holy grail
for 2000 years is in fact unattainable
and he showed this very clearly
people who work in fields where girdle's
theorem apply
are aware of this but the general public
is not
so what you now learn when you study the
philosophy of science
is that the most that you can require
of a system of explanation
is that it be consistent unto itself
a theory of explanation which is
consistent unto itself
has arrived at the highest plane
of uh human
knowability there is no meta system
which can look down at five
self-consistent systems
and say well a and b are true
and c d and f are false well
now astrology is a self-consistent
closed system of explanation just
like science is but science will presume
to judge astrology and dismiss
it and we have all gotten into the habit
of thinking that if you have an
idea and you want to know whether it's
true or not
you take it to scientists and lay it
before them the way a cat
lays a rat at its master's feet and then
they
the scientists say yay or nay but
actually scientists are part of a
priesthood
and act to preserve their turf and very
rarely point out
that if a system is self-consistent
that's as far as it can be taken and
this is very important to remember
science
what is not under attack here
is reason i'm very concerned to make the
differentiation between
science and reason because and
and there is a tendency in modern
society and i'm sure there are
speakers who have occupied this chair
who have not
felt the obligation to reason at
all you know i mean they're they're
operating in a realm where
it's whatever you say it is as fast as
you can
think it up and
that's not where i'm coming from so i
think science is
a very very important branch of art
and if we could get the scientists to
admit that the ultimate criteria for
deciding how a person shall
choose among competing explanatory
systems is aesthetic it's a matter of
choice and taste
there is no higher arbiter of meaning
[Music]
you